que alcance puede tener este
reconocimiento y cuanto cree usted que
este movimiento incrementa las tensiones
en ucrania
pero definitivamente era un poco crónica
de algo anunciado en el sentido de que
si las tensiones iban en creyendo en
algún momento la solicitud de la duma
rusa de que se reconocieran la
independencia de las repúblicas iba a
ser asumida por putin y de hecho eso es
lo que hizo ahora esto desde luego
implica que hay una decisión de apoyar
la autonomía de lugansk y daniels en
oposición a los intereses de ucrania el
gobierno central de ucrania pero es el
resultado de que ucrania tampoco cumplió
en su momento con los acuerdos de minsk
establecidos en el 14 en 2014 2015 era
el sentido de incorporar a estas
repúblicas o repúblicas con cierto grado
de autonomía dentro de una nueva
estructura política de ucrania esto se
fue demorando
oponiéndose el presidente es el ente que
lo había prometido pero no se avanzó en
el marco de los acuerdos establecidos lo
que se llama el grupo normandía con
francia y con alemania como garantes
era un resultado esperable en función de
el incremento de las tensiones en este
momento en la región y desde el nuevo de
las presiones que se están ejerciendo
desde occidente
sobre rusia para que de alguna manera
ucrania sea un miembro más de la
comunidad occidental más que nada del
espacio europeo y eventualmente que
pueda adherirse a la organización del
tratado del atlántico norte
y cree usted que es posible un
movimiento de des escalada después de
este discurso de putin
yo creo que esto ha ido en creciendo
sistemáticamente y creo que no es
responsabilidad solamente del lado ruso
sino que también en las declaraciones el
otro día del presidente vaivén
en el sentido de decir que ya había
tomado la decisión de invadir ucrania
pero son todos elementos de lado y lado
que han ido agregando
y
más sustancia a la escalada misma es
esto esto es hace muy difícil que en
este momento se pueden recurrir a los
canales diplomáticos tradicionales para
que se pueda
avanzar en alguna forma de negociación
en torno a la situación de ucrania yo
creo que
esto es un poco también resultado de las
presiones que se han venido ejerciendo
de lado y lado